nos dicen que la gráfica de la función
fx igual a x al cuadrado se encuentra
por aquí es esta gráfica gris y por otro
lado quieren que grafique mos la función
g x igual a x menos 2 al cuadrado menos
4 osea quieren que utilicemos esta
gráfica interactiva azul para graficar
esta función y por cierto este es un
ejercicio llamado traslada funciones de
la página de cam academy así es que como
puedes ver en esta gráfica interactiva
podemos mover estos dos puntos podemos
modificar la gráfica azul pero lo que
realmente queremos hacer con esta
gráfica azul es graficar a la función g
de x de aquí así es que lo que podemos
empezar haciendo es que la gráfica azul
se parezca a la gráfica de x al cuadrado
aunque para eso pues lo ponemos
aquí lo que acabamos de hacer es que
estas dos gráficas coincidan
completamente y entonces ahora nos vamos
a poner a pensar en las diferencias
entre estas dos funciones g de x por acá
en lugar de tener simplemente una x al
cuadrado tiene un x menos 2 al cuadrado
y bueno una forma de pensar en todo esto
es pensar en el 0 por ejemplo si x es
igual a 0 0 al cuadrado es 0 pero como
lo podemos hacer en esta función bueno
cómo lo podemos hacer para que esto de
aquí sea igual a 0 pues para que este
pedazo de aquí sea igual a 0 x tiene que
ser igual a 2 porque hay porque 2 menos
dos al cuadrado si es igual a cero y
bueno aquí no estamos tomando en cuenta
todavía al menos cuatro pero eso lo
vamos a ver más adelante así es que lo
que tenemos que hacer es mover toda la
gráfica azul dos lugares a la derecha
dos lugares a la derecha
dos lugares a la derecha este número de
aquí este 2 representa cuántos lugares a
la derecha nos tenemos que mover a veces
es un poquito contraintuitivo el hecho
de tener por aquí un menos porque cuando
vemos este menos muchas veces sentimos
que nos tenemos que mover hacia la
izquierda pero en este caso no porque
para llegar a este punto en esta función
tenemos que es 0 al cuadrado es 0 sin
embargo para que este pedazo sea igual a
cero todo este paréntesis tiene que ser
igual a cero o sea que tengo que poner
aquí un 2 y entonces si ya tenemos 2
menos 20 al cuadrado x tiene que ser
igual a 2 así es que estamos moviendo la
gráfica dos lugares hacia la derecha y
bueno ahora sí ya llegamos a la parte en
la que hablamos del -4 y esto es mucho
más intuitivo por lo menos así fue para
mí cuando lo aprendí esto lo único que
hace es mover la gráfica cuatro lugares
hacia abajo porque
o sea el valor que nos salga en x menos
2 al cuadrado le tenemos que restar 4 o
sea mover la cuatro lugares hacia abajo
porque simplemente estamos moviendo la
gráfica cuatro lugares hacia abajo así
es que este punto lo vamos a mover de
las coordenadas 59 a la coordenada 5,5 1
2 3 4 y este punto lo vamos a mover de
la coordenada 20 a la coordenada 2 - 4
greg 1 2 3 4 y listo
si nos quedó bien no pero bueno aquí lo
que podemos ver es que la función g es
igual a la función efe
pero trasladada dos lugares hacia la
derecha
cuatro lugares hacia abajo y bueno si
nos ponemos a observar este vértice lo
movimos dos a la derecha y cuatro hacia
abajo y este otro vértice también estaba
por aquí y lo movimos dos a la derecha y
cuatro hacia abajo y listo ya terminamos
ya gráfica moza la función g de x que es
una traslación de la función fx